Speaker 1: We have yet another data point in
which we find that while claiming that the left
was censoring the right on Twitter and elsewhere,
the Trump administration was demanding others be
censored. So let let me back up a little bit as we
start to talk about this story. During the first
I guess, the first couple of days of hearings
about the weaponization of big tech or whatever
it was we learned we learned that the Trump
administration wanted celebrity. Chrissy Teigen
censored for an insult she made about
President Donald Trump. Let me remind you,
we this remember, these were hearings meant
to make the left look bad and they made the
right look like triggered snowflakes.
Speaker 2: Miss nervously earlier you
testified about a 2019 tweet. Yeah, that was about
President Trump. And I think it's from Mr. Keegan.
What was the tweet about?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: Would you like me to give the direct
quote? Yeah. Please excuse my language. This is
a direct quote, but Chrissy Teigen referred
to Donald Trump as a pussy ass bitch.
Speaker 2: Okay, Free speech. And what happened
after Ms.. Teigen posted her tweet? What did the
White House do? What did the Trump White House do?
Speaker 3: Right, For my understanding. The
White House reached out to ask that this
tweet be removed. It was my team's job,
the spell underneath the policy for abusive
behaviors. And we evaluate it underneath our
insults policy. At that time, up to three insults
were allowed. And so it was our job to determine
how many insults were included within that phrase.
Speaker 2: So the Trump White House reached out,
not an agency, but the White House reached
out and request that you remove the.
Speaker 3: Tweet From my understanding, yes.
Speaker 1: Okay. So the story that they were
telling on the right is it's the left that
constantly wants to do censorship and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. A celebrity insults Trump
and they try to get the tweet deleted. But we now
know that that's not the only such example. We
have also now learned that the Trump White House
was pressuring Disney, meaning ABC, to censor
Jimmy Kimmel. This is at this point. Are we
surprised by this at all? Rolling Stone article.
The former president was so incensed by the late
night host Jimmy Kimmel making fun of him that he
had his staff take action. This was in early 2018.
The American national security apparatus was
fixated on reports that North Korea was building
nuclear weapons, which could reach the U.S.
or that Russia was plotting chemical weapons
assassinations in Europe. Trump, meanwhile,
was busy targeting his idea of an enemy of the
state. Late night host Jimmy Kimmel. According
to two former Trump administration officials,
Trump was so upset by Jimmy Kimmel's comedic jabs
that he directed White House staff to call up one
of Disney's top executives in DC to complain and
demand action. ABC is owned by Disney in at least
two separate phone calls that occurred around
the time Trump was finishing his first year in
office. The White House conveyed the severity of
Trump's fury with Kimmel to Disney. Trump's staff
mentioned the leader of the free world, wanted
the billion dollar company to reign in Jimmy
Kimmel for trashing Trump. And Trump felt that
Kimmel had, in the characterization of a former
administration official, been very dishonest and
doing things that Trump would have sued over.
The incident was so bizarre. News of it spread
around the corridors of power in D.C.. Other
administration officials who had nothing to
do with the pressure campaign expressed they
were confused that the way that they express
hearing from Disney, that they were confused,
that the White House was telling them
Trump wants to tone down the humor. They
are the triggered snowflakes. And I know we've
said it so many times before. Accusations are
confessions and it's projection and all of these
different things. It really is the truth. And from
the Twitter files, we learned basically that
the Trump administration had the same access,
if that's what you want to call it. To request
things be removed as the Biden campaign remember
Trump administration, Biden campaign. And from all
of these anecdotes, we're learning that the Trump
White House was regularly trying to use their
powers of censorship while claiming that it is
the left that was trying to censor them. It is yet
another case where the truth is the opposite of
what they tell us. I am sure these two examples
that we mentioned today aren't the only ones.
Did you know that half of Americans are deficient
in vitamin A, vitamin C and magnesium? Most
Americans are deficient in vitamin D. I take
vitamin D during the winter. It is sometimes
difficult to eat exactly the right amount of each
food to get exactly what you need. I just make my
life simpler with age one by athletic greens
in the morning. One scoop of ag one. I get the
entire day's worth of 75 high quality vitamins,
minerals and Whole foods sourced ingredients. It's
what I want. It's no more, it's no less. It's not
making any outlandish claims. It's just an easy,
sustainable routine. I've tried different ways
of taking vitamins. Ag1 is cheaper, it's quicker,
it's tastier. I'm not fumbling around with
different capsules. It tastes great to drink
straight with water. Sometimes I'll put it in a
smoothie or shake. It's simple. It's something
easy you can do. Going into the New Year, staying
properly nourished, athletic greens is giving
my audience a free year supply of Vitamin D. I
take that every day in winter. Plus, you'll get
five free travel packs of AG one Go to athletic
green XCOM slash Pacman. The link is down below.